what's up motion designers if you've
spent any amount of time in the motion
design world you may be aware there's a
lot of plugins and scripts that exist
out there for us to help us improve our
workflows and to make some cool effects
and typically I'm pretty Discerning
about what plugins or scripts I use I
don't buy a lot of them but I recently
came across a plug-in that blew my mind
and today we're going to talk about what
that is so let's check it out
[Music]
thank you
hey what's up my name is Cameron with
motion science and as I said we're going
to talk about a plug-in today called
dehancer that just really blew my mind
but before we jump into the video I just
want to tell you really quickly I've got
a free gift for you over at
motionscience.tv guide it's my guide on
mastering organic motion design and
these are it's a it's a guy that's full
of tips and tricks that will help you
create renders that aren't so digital
looking right we see a lot of renders
that are that are made today at least I
do I see a lot of Runners that just look
really digital straight out of the box
and if you want to get renders that look
like mine that look very organic and
tactile you definitely want to check out
my guide as I said it's free it's
motionscience.tv guide go download it
check it out okay so let's talk about
this plug-in called dehancer and what
this plugin is is it essentially adds a
film look uh to your work that could be
footage that could be Graphics it
doesn't really matter now I'm not a
super her techie guy when it comes to
like breaking down what algorithms or
why this this application this effect
works the way that it does I just know
that when I see something that looks
good or see something that works I like
to dive in and kind of explore it so
that's what I did and that's what I want
to show you today we're not going to
talk about the technicalities of why
this emulates film there's plenty of
videos out there that that do discuss
that but let's jump into after effects
and let me show you what it can do all
right so here we are in After Effects
and what I'm using for an example here
is it is a course from motion science
called Beyond title design and this is a
course that's about creating a concept
for title sequence and then ex you know
designing the title sequence and then
animating the title sequence and
finishing it if you haven't checked out
the course definitely do it's an awesome
course put together from by Ryan but you
can see here
um if I just kind of scroll through it
I mean the visuals are powerful right we
got really powerful visuals here so what
we have here is some layers of text some
some animation we've created we've got
some grade applied to the look we've got
some grain as well and typically this is
how we work right we add a grain effect
from After Effects like we see here so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take a screenshot here and just show you
I'm going to zoom in here so we're at
Full Resolution but we're at 200 so it
might look a little a little grainy
there but this is
where we're currently at I'm gonna turn
off that grain so you can see this is
what the grain looks like and this is
without right so now I'm going to come
to the top of my layer stack here
and I'm going to add a new adjustment
layer now the reason I'm adding this to
the top of my layer stack I want the
film look to affect everything uh here
in the composition so it's an adjustable
layer I'm just going to hit return and
I'm going to call this dehancer
and there we go and we're going to go up
to effect and we're going to go down
here to film emulation dehancer Pro uh
currently version 1.3 and immediately
you can see here what the grain looks
like right I go back and I show the
snapshot this is what it looked like
with just the after effects green and
this is with the the dehancer over the
top now the dehancer is emulating film
and it is changing the colors the tones
of the composition so we have to be
aware of that what I love about this is
there's so many different presets here
right so I just kind of like play around
and and look for ones that really kind
of float my boat
oh
foreign
and like I said you can see that I'm
instantly getting some really
interesting looks here right
so what I also like about this is the
push pull option here in the effects we
can go down to a negative two which
looks just like this I can undo that
come back go to a positive two and we've
got to look just like this what's also
really awesome about this plug-in is the
bloom section here now one gripe I have
in this version is that all of the
enabled buttons are or check boxes are
at the bottom of each section which I
wish they were at the top here and maybe
they'll change that in future versions
so if we go like to film grain it's
enabled down here at the bottom
halation again down here at the bottom
halation is a really cool effect you can
see it adds like this kind of red glow
to everything no I don't love it so much
with the type here
um but we can you know turn things up
like Source limiter and it kind of turns
it off the type and we can see a little
bit
of it up here in the Rock but not enough
uh for my needs but again like the bloom
I love this Bloom effect there's some
different settings you can use you can
amplify it up in here
you know always like a kind of a minimal
effect
um
but that's with Bloom and that's without
so it just adds a really nice touch to
it now I really like this color setting
as well looks really nice Fuji color 100
um and I'll jump to another scene here
let's find one here's a great one
to kind of zoom out so I'll turn the
answer off we'll turn grain back on
we'll take a quick snapshot here
turn it on turn grain back off
and just by default you can see here how
much more natural looking uh the
composition looks right the composing
looks just really nice so that's the
original which looks nice in itself and
then we add this to answer plug and just
adds that extra bit of like realism uh
to the composition it just looks really
awesome
again I could go in I could change I
could push pull if I wanted to
that's nice let's go the opposite way
here
don't love that as much
back to the original uh again there's
some really nice black and white presets
in here some really interesting
I've seen a lot of different
grain plug-ins over the years I've been
going way back I've been in After
Effects for a long time and this is by
far the best one I've seen so that's why
I'm talking about in this video because
I'm really impressed with it
again we could go back here to the Fuji
color 100
and that's with the answer so let's take
a quick snapshot of that turn that off
and again
dehancer
not the non-dihancer right just look how
nice that looks
absolutely love it so let's let me show
you one more example here so what we
have here is a very simple title
sequence I set up and I used mid journey
to create this image and I'll just break
it down for you really quickly here but
what I did
um was here's the basic image I blew it
up
uh I added some light rays to it because
we have this tunnel back here
and I also added a scale effect to it
and with the scale effect uh you can see
I'm going from 133 percent up to 147
right so we just have this basic kind of
push in here and I'll go ahead and go to
half res so we can see this a little
quicker but it's just a simple push into
the image right and there's some light
rays kind of coming at us as we're
pushing in uh and then I made it a lot
more interesting oh and one more thing I
want to point out here is I took the
Anchor Point uh down here
to the to the top of the road right so
like I did that because we're pushing
into that point of the road now by
default The Anchor Point is going to be
up in here and if we scale into that
um
it kind of works but it doesn't look
like I'm traveling down that road so
that's the look I'm going for here so
move the Anchor Point back down there
and then here's a little trick for you
I applied an effect called Optics
compensation and if I turn that on and I
showed the the effect here I've got it
set to a reverse lens Distortion which
that's important to do
um so just click this little box here
and I set a field of view of 50 at the
beginning and I set a field of view of
81.6 at the end you kind of have to play
around with those variables and then I
set the View Center uh to be where my
Anchor Point is for the scale and when I
do that you can see here this Optics
compensation is creating this effect
like it's creating Parallax right and it
looks like we're kind of pushing through
these trees so with Optics composition
that's what it looks like and without
this is what it looks like right it's a
very flat image right just very flat
looks like almost kind of pushing in on
a photograph but with Optics
compensation it looks like it's kind of
warping and we're moving through that
image okay so this is one way that you
can take like mid Journey images of
things like tunnels or hallways and
things like that and
give it some Parallax some extra depth
that we wouldn't normally have
so I've got that and then I took this
text and what I did was on this text I
scaled the text from 100
up to 155 and then again I took that
Anchor Point for that text which would
normally be here in the center or on the
edge or whatever and I put it over here
near where the Anchor Point is for the
road turned out to be exact
and by doing that it makes the text
scale up from this point so it looks
when we preview it it looks like it's
creating Parallax right like it's almost
part of this road even though there's no
3D camera here there's no 3D happening
just by positioning The Anchor Point
back here on the road
scaling it up slightly more than the
image scales up
it creates a sense of Parallax within
this this image okay so that's what I'm
doing here
and
let's go back to full res
so we can really see it and then what I
did is I applied an adjustment layer
over the top just like we did in the
previous example and I played around
with some different settings and for
this one I liked these three
um Loma Chrome was really awesome I
turned on some some Bloom here and
that's basically it I think I also added
some vignette yeah I enabled the
vignette so that's without and that's
with it's got a really nice vignette
feature to the plug-in and if I preview
this
and just kind of let it go it's through
its thing you can see how much more
cinematic this looks right I already had
a really powerful scene to begin with
with the background image with the
Optics compensation and with the text
kind of coming out the camera but by
adding this dehancer Pro over the top
I mean just look how nice that looks
that film grain
the coloring it that the hands are just
really pulled everything together and
unified everything now I tell a lot of
videos
and even in my guide I talk about how
important it is to have things like
grain over the top to help unify
different elements of the composition
and this dehancer plug-in just really
does a nice job of doing that
so that is with vignette so if I turn
vignette off you can see the difference
there if I turn Bloom off the bloom
really hits these highlights nice here
in the road it hits the text nice so
again off
and like look at that text right here
with
on off and then the road and then the
the light coming from the tunnel
really nice so that's a really nice
preset there if I turn that one off and
go to this next one
I liked this one a lot as well
totally different tones and that's
what's so awesome about this plug-in too
is it can create you know different
looks and tones very quickly which I
absolutely love a lot of times for me
when I get a plug-in
the presets Straight Out of the Box
don't necessarily work now there's a few
plugins out there that do work and this
is one of them which is awesome
and then here's another look which kind
of keeps the the same similar tones that
we already had so this is without and
with but just look how nice that grain
is that it adds here right so let's go
without and with that grain just adds an
entirely new level of cinematic feel
look and feel to that project so that's
what I got for you today my friends uh
that is the hanser plug-in you can
actually get 10 off there's a coupon
code below this video it's just motion
science one word motion science will
save you 10 off this this uh plug-in I
highly recommend it if you've got the
the money to spend on a plug-in this is
one to get it is absolutely awesome
again let me remind you very quickly I
have a free guide over at
motionscience.tv guide
motionscience.tv guide it's full of tips
and tricks to create more organic
looking motion design like we see here
right this is organic motion design this
isn't that digital feel that I see
across the board so many different
places so definitely check it out and uh
as always thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next video
foreign